good morning Hank good morning John it
is Wednesday I'm not really in a mood to
make a proper video here's my oh my turf
you guys bringing us flowers
oh thanks something that starts please
however we are going to play a game of
word association today and then you're
going to continue the game in comments
I'm going to start now lemon pie
meringue mushroom pizza corndog the
hotdogs dachshund ah poop in a Nintendo
and Sonic the Hedgehog ah Mario Luigi
Princess Catherine oh sweet ah
peppermint um uh minty um
Mitt Romney um
politician George Bush rich people
Mountain Brook hahahahahaha where we are
right now um
country clubs golf clubs uh disco balls
back to go back to Garland's and disco
it's just beautiful in a loop just
beautiful disco golf balls
disco golf ball loop yes somebody right
now is making disco golf balls on
country yeah with you they should be
selling those on Etsy right now yeah
they will be
don't worry I'll buy dftba.com now
available for pre-order just go golf
balls not really not really but you
can't get a pizza John shirt um basket
um
weaving um underwater swimming scuba um
acronyms that are axial on with not a
word acronyms there you go initialism
dftba awesome
make uh uh George Washington
that's what Hank reminds me I remind
myself of George Washington I don't know
if you've ever known I'm really good
general obelisks ah phallus no no no
that's it's just all balls and fallacies
here they're here where am I supposed to
go from phallus what is that supposed to
make me think of um Greek or possibly
Latin Socrates oh he is either Greek or
Latin I know Chris I know from crash
course you will soon find out my friend
in Episode three of crash course
Socrates makes me think of Hemlock uh
makes me think of pine makes me think of
SAP turpentine makes me think of that
turpentine you smell that's not as I was
a word
well that turpentine ease mount marble
um
Venice Italy mmm
corruption Berlusconi sex with seventeen
year old girls off no also not a word
not a word Jersey the headline of the
Economist with Silvio Berlusconi and it
just said the headline on the cover was
the man who screwed an entire country so
we're gonna stop there and you're going
to start at Silvio Berlusconi hate you a
dog
the doggy so the job now is that in
comments you the nerdfighters will
continue our game of word association
say hi to chief best wishes